[Music]
how long ago did we go to japan three
years ago three years ago it was so fun
but the first time i went there it was
um for a job and the people who took us
there took us to a very fancy restaurant
and
i i did learn this about japanese
culture which i love it's it's very
respectful to
show your appreciation for the other
culture and in this case we were at a
restaurant it was for their food and
they're bringing out and they were proud
there's a lot of pride in
in what they do and uh the preparation
of the food and all that and the
presentation so they brought out and the
food was incredible god it was a
delicious but what their specialty and
the thing that they were most proud of
was a shot glass
with
liquid in it that was
not discernible to me at the time and
there was a
yolk a yolk a quail egg yolk say that
again yolk yol yolk it's a yeah i'm hung
up on the l there's an l in yoke you
don't have to pronounce it there's a
there's a k and i don't
i don't
but i don't often say it i say knife a
lot more than i say yolk yolk i yolk
anyway there's a yolk in it yeah a quail
a little yolk and swimming in this
mixture was uh a minnow a live minnow
swimming around
to and fro
kind of frightened looking of course
and um you can judge looks of minnows
well i guess almonds look frightened
okay yes okay you caught me i had to
drink it eat it because it was impolite
not to i remember the sensation of the
minnow sliding down well now that you've
sufficiently turned my stomach uh let's
get into the show
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i'm
your times nauseating host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
with me as always is my um now queasy
brother
uh christian long it's a gross story but
i understand the um
the impetus to do it
you can't you have to turn it away
they're also not only are they is
respect such an important thing um the
service there is so impeccable
that the last thing you want to do is
deny them in any way i know i know to be
i would eat just about anything in japan
well i'll remember you know we ate
something oh maybe we shouldn't talk
about this oh yeah
horse justin i ate horse horse
raw horse raw horse yeah we shouldn't
talk about i i never will again i don't
in fairness we didn't know what it was
until after we had eaten it that's true
that is true and then a friend that was
a friend we just met um
owie shout out if she's listening owie
said that wait we very excited leaks we
were like what was that
uh very excitedly she said
horse
yeah horse
i said say it was that
she had a much cuter voice than that i'm
making her sound like i know like
genghis khan or something
no i was like an adorable japanese woman
oh my god genghis khan what if
how much could you love power like he
i do isn't like it enough to like just
conquer attack availa like so why are we
talking about genghis khan yeah okay
speaking of genghis khan well speaking
of uh really exotic we have one of the
great despots of the world on the show
today yeah he's a mongol of course
another tyrannical mongol um
we know we were talking about the exotic
foods in japan because the one thing i
didn't eat and i don't i think don't
think i would maybe that's my limit is
blowfish i don't think i would go
go there because it's dangerous it's
deadly it's not yeah more than dangerous
yeah if it's not cut properly is that
what it is
it can kill you i think that is what it
is it's um and i forget the percent
crazy it must you know it must be really
delicious you think or is it just like a
badge of honor that you've done maybe i
know how did it become a badge of honor
if it wasn't delicious in the evolution
of eating blowfish right it must have
been it must be delicious
or is it a thing that was incorporated
in the culture like if you can survive
this if you die you know you weren't
worthy of maybe it was part of their
folk or their their
spirituality i don't know why are we
talking about blowfish well now i'm
curious to well speak it up speaking of
slow fish and fish being scared yes you
know you know that's a fish that you
know when it's scared
you know
um anyway
well no it just [ __ ] blows up oh yeah
yeah christian
i'm it's not great for my clownfish
impression
oh really now do your macro
that's mackerels aren't squishy no
that's really awful looking by the way
um yeah why are we talking about
blowfish well we have one of the uh
one of the great blowfish the guy who
kind of like ran
one of the most famous groups of
blowfish would you say
we have the former lead singer of the
iconic legendary
american rock band hoodie and the
blowfish on the show today his name is
darius rucker he is now a
legendary uh single solo act and an
incredible country music performer uh
darius rucker is he has a new album
coming out we're going to talk about it
he's also one of he has become
he went from being the lead singer of
this iconic rock band in the 90s into
the 2000s and then he
i would say he reinvented himself um
as a country music solo act
and he's since in the last 15 16 years
become
one of the by far the biggest
musicians in country music and in fact
he is one of
three
african-american members of the grand
ole opry no k well we talk about one of
the others i would imagine charlie pride
that's correct yeah um and he talks
about
well we'll get into it i'll let you know
what
better to let him everyone knows darius
rucker um either his solo work or who
doing the blowfish or both he's a
grammy-winning
amazing musician incredible music and if
you grew up in the night i never met him
i never we have never met um but of
course i grew up in the 90s i was coming
of age in the 90s and
that's when i would learn to drive in
the 90s so when you're when i was
driving it was the radio you know you
listen to the radio and you drive around
and hooting the blowfish were everywhere
everywhere it was it was you so
ubiquitous and they never got annoying
no for a band that was everywhere i
never i know i was like oh another
hoodie in the blue fish no i always
always wanted to listen and when they
pop on the right when they come on the
radio now pop on when they come on um it
always makes me happy oh they want to be
with you
right
make you happy uh yeah yeah just because
like the two just as those melodies are
so good great uh that even you doing it
is looking at me even me well you're
looking at me it's a weird weird time to
see you know only one will be with you
two feet away from each other uh anyway
here is um i do now i'm sure you only
want to be with darius rucker that's a
good segue thank you very well done i'm
taking a segway course in that was this
that sponsor great courses great courses
yeah i'm doing one in segways i took i
took a pickling course the other day i'm
very excited about getting to pickling
anyway who cares let's see who cares all
right here it is uh this it was a great
segue and i ruined it sorry i ruined it
well no i had to brag about my oh right
you did uh but here it is
not as good a segway but we are excited
uh to have the the great uh legendary
he'll be in the grand ole opry he isn't
the grand ole opry currently currently
he's in the lifetime membership oh
that's right you don't get i mean
hopefully he doesn't yeah yeah
but for the time being he's in there and
he's there to stay and uh here he is on
the show darius rucker life could be a
dream
[Music]
hello hello
how's it going i'm good it's so nice to
see you
good to see you too justin how are you
doing man yeah i'm good i'm really good
where exactly are you i'm in chicago oh
okay you're a full-time home no no i'm
just here i got a golf tournament i
gotta play tomorrow
okay so no affiliation other than just
for the night no just for the night
absolutely easy you enjoy golfing i do
play a lot of goals yeah i play too much
golf
is it one of those things where it's
like you'll do any i have a friend who's
like doesn't really know the chair i
mean i'm sure you know the charity but
he's like he'll just do anything just
like as an excuse yeah just to go play
absolutely yeah absolutely
i'm in on that
what's what's the greatest if you had
your druthers if you could just like
play anywhere in the world where would
your uh oh i would play augusta national
every day if i could play anywhere i
could play there every day yeah as for
someone who i know nothing about golf
but i hear but why what makes that so
because i've heard other golfing
fanatics say that what what makes that
so special it's an amazing place i mean
the way the the way they keep it and how
but i think the thing that really makes
it special is just the history yeah the
history of all that's going on there and
you know you remember all those shots
and those places you're walking and
stuff like that makes it pretty awesome
and there's there must be places that
you've played like that i mean you
probably have a similar sense when you
play the grand ole opry or something
oh absolutely you know red rocks red
rocks right um yeah when you play there
you remember it forever oh yeah
i love talking to musicians about that
because i know it's something i'll never
really
no i mean none of us will people listen
to this or like i think everyone has
this fascination with that feeling that
you have connecting with an audience and
i've tried i've tried to ask musicians
about that like to like describe it to
me you know but it's um oh you can't
describe it i can't yeah
those moments
when
it's just perfect
and everybody's singing and you're
singing and the band sounds amazing and
and you can feel the energy and you can
feel how happy everybody is i mean those
that i mean to feel that
i'd play for free you know i mean it's
just it's so it's really
unbelievable how because this is all
i've ever wanted to do it is
a kid
yeah that was four years old really i
thought i was i said i'm gonna be a
singer someday yeah i wanted to be al
green
that's a funny thing for a kid to want
to be i mean specifically al green
for a kid i know i wanted to be a little
i wanted to have on the all-white suit
he's just so like he's such a sensual
performer for a kid it's so funny he was
just the man to me he was the man my mom
was a big fan so i heard him a lot
yeah i read you grew up in a you have a
lot of siblings you described as being
like crammed into a house very small
space yeah it's a small house you know
it's a it's a small house but i loved it
i loved my childhood i go back and do it
right now you know we had a great
neighborhood my brother was what he was
but my sisters were great my mom was
great
my younger brother was great it was uh
it was one of those things i didn't we
didn't have much
but it didn't matter we always had
something to do yeah and probably didn't
know have any frame of reference that's
the thing for like people who there's
not that wanting of things because it's
like you just that's what you knew
absolutely you know you i mean
the the what you just said is a great
explanation you didn't want anything
because you knew you couldn't have it
right it's right you know i mean i was
big into wrestling as a kid and i mean i
knew i couldn't get any wrestling i
can't get any magazines so when my mom
went to the grocery store while she
walked around the grocery store i got to
sit in the little magazine section and
read all the mag the wrestling magazine
you know
you know that was
how we did it but did you see other kid
were there other kids do you ever
remember thinking god i wish
you know timmy down the street gets to
have his own wrestling ringers i mean
were there kids was there more affluence
around you i'm starting the church
absolutely yeah absolutely even our like
neighbors in our neighborhood you know
you know getting mopeds and stuff like
that you know i wouldn't get a mope i
won't get in a moped
for nothing
i was lucky if i had a bicycle
let alone a moped so but you know like
when video games started coming out you
know i wasn't getting atari there was no
chance i was ever going to get that
right you can't exactly play video games
while your mom shops
yeah it's not the same yeah no so but it
was but for the i you know i looked back
it was never time when i was like i wish
that was that guy
pretty happy with being me so darius you
didn't i'm fascinated by this by people
who then who grew up grow up like that
and then achieve so much success that
they can now
get whatever they want that they can
have things um did you find yourself did
you ever go through a phase where you
were like because this seems to be a
common thing where you know you want to
acquire
things you you want things no yeah no
i'm still on that i'm still in that
opposite phase i'm still
i'm still praying it doesn't go away
still praying something stupid doesn't
happen and it goes away so i'm just
i've never been a like i'm not a car guy
huh you know
if i have real estate it's for the
investment it's not for anything else is
that because i want something dangerous
for an investment it's practical
yeah you know i got a couple watches but
i'm not that guy yeah that's good are
you still in charleston the charleston
area live in charleston
well then yeah i love
obviously great city but um is your
family still there yeah oh my i got one
brother moved away but my sisters are
all still there so cool
how i love it but then why the dog i
heard you're a dolphins fan why why am i
yeah why
when i was a kid i i remember this like
it was yesterday i was five years old
and uh
the dolphins
were playing the cowboys in the super
bowl in 71. oh wow
they're getting some greasy and
starbucks bob gracie yeah that whole
team yeah and uh bob griese and larry
zonka and jim kick and so uh we were
having a party at the house and all my
cousins were there my my aunts and
uncles and
so i was going around asking everybody
who they were going for you know who
they were pulling for and everybody was
pulling for the cowboys yeah america
everybody
yeah and so i decided that i was pulling
for the dolphins ah
just the natural contrarian that exactly
you know and
i'll never forget they lost i'll never
forget if they lost and i cried oh i
cried that's so i cried isn't that funny
to think back darius i i threw a fit
when the ram for some reason i grew up
in connecticut i love the rams the la
ram because the dick eric dickerson
dickerson yeah i just thought he was the
coolest and they
they lost i mean they they got blown out
uh in the nfc championship game i think
it was the 86 it was the years the bears
yeah you're affiliated but like you're
in chicago uh
yeah it was the year they went and i was
um
despondent yes isn't it insane to look
back at that and
uh what did what did your family do with
those mom because now you know you're
raising kids you're what does your
family do with a moment like that how do
you treat a kid who's like crying over
something so stupid
oh man i i always i was an emotional
little kid i cried i cried a lot
so they they were they were
yeah they were used to it but uh yeah i
mean they tell all the stories i love it
when someone brings somebody around they
tell all the stories but uh yeah you
know
i love that we have those stories
because we have so much fun as kids yeah
they remember all that stuff yeah yeah
you're you're um
and you're you're so close with most of
your siblings did you
was it do you remember there being a lot
of music you mentioned your mom played
out green was that
was it strictly you're from your mom or
was your whole family kind of like
immersed in it everybody was in the
music i mean you know whether my sisters
were singing in the choir or or my mom
and my mom
you know and everybody music was and
music was always in the house like
somebody was always playing music you
know when those big high-fives in the in
the living room you know the records
that the sliding door the records under
and there was always somebody in there
playing music it was just it was just
part of a bumpering but but at that
point i imagine at what point i guess
did it become
did it go from like oh this is just
something that's around and i love to
i i could do this like i want to do this
for forever oh young kid yeah it was
four it really was that yeah four or
five when i was
i would get you know my mom would have
company over and i would get the little
salt and pepper shaker
and go be out and sing the al green
songs film
you know i just wanted to get up and
sing for people ever since i was a kid
oh wow that's really cool and then and
do you have like the kind of parents
who were
dissuaded that or did they encourage
you to oh my mom always encouraged me my
mom always encourages always never you
know i always tell the story about like
you know i had older cousins who love to
mess with me and everything who love to
give me a hard time and
you know they'd come in the house and
i'd be listening to you know kenny
rogers or i'd be listening to cheap
trick or kiss or something you know and
and uh they'd start giving me crap you
know why you listening to that white boy
music boy my mom would just
my mom would come and get a hold of them
and let them know that i could listen to
whatever i want to listen to and they
need to leave me alone and yeah and she
was always
my biggest champion she always told me i
could go do it why not
that's interesting
it's such an interesting thing darius
that you were
that they teased you about that and then
i imagine
then you have to i'm sure the whole
other side the like
the white kids must have been
like well this is our thing you know i
mean you must have gotten oh absolutely
you know both sides you do when i mean
the whole time everything i've done in
music
it's been it's been that way yeah you
know it's it's what are you doing here
or you don't belong here one is one of
the two things and but you know i don't
care man well all right you're lucky i
mean i've been talking a lot lately
about thinking a lot about how
those formative years like how they
really for better for worse really like
stick with you really inform
so much of your life and and
yeah one thing you said about your mom i
mean
thank god that moment of encouragement
otherwise you may have been swayed to
you know go with some crowd or not do
your own oh absolutely if my mom wasn't
in my corner as much as she was i
wouldn't have been so sure of what i
wanted to do i wouldn't have been so
secure and
thinking i could do it because there was
never anybody that looked like me that
was doing things like the singing i mean
you know you had hendrix who else was
there you know lenny kravitz came along
and started singing rock and roll but
it's like when i the people i was
looking for when i was looking for rock
and roll heroes there weren't a lot of
black rock roll heroes for me to find
that's true and like and certainly some
of that sound that you described i mean
like kenny i'm thinking of kenny rogers
like oh yeah kenny rogers is a very
yeah lenny kravitz and jimi hendrix but
so
so removed from somebody like kenny i
was just so different uh yeah
i mean but that that was that was it for
me as a kid i didn't care about what
john i didn't think about this is
country music but this is rock and roll
yeah i just talked about i just thought
i liked that song yeah it was all about
a soul
yeah i bet well and and then you've had
another
i mean the thing i remember
most about after hooting the blowfish i
remember
i remember getting like a little taste
of this you had gone on this whole new
path a country path
and and became wildly successful doing
it obviously people know this um but i
don't have to rehash this and which is
what you're
you're now known for this really now is
what you're doing but but i remember
thinking wow
that because i knew you so well as
this one thing and i remember thinking
what a crazy what a like reinvention but
i wonder like
is that how you saw it i mean was it
that to you or was it just like oh [ __ ]
i like this [ __ ] i like doing this
somebody somebody said that the other
day that i reinvented myself and i never
thought that at all i just want to sing
countries i it was never a time when i
sat down and i'd go i'm going to take
this it wasn't like
no it was just i wanted you know
one of the hootie guys said he didn't
want to tour he wouldn't be a touring
band anymore and i'd been saying for
years i was going to make a country
record someday and so i was just going
to go do it it wasn't like i really i'll
be honest with you
even when i got a record deal
i didn't think i was going to have this
kind of success there just was
there was no
there was no multiplier that i could see
where
it was going to work because
all there was so many strikes against it
what what was the biggest i mean name
what are the topics oh the biggest i
think i think the top three is coming
from coming from rock and roll coming
from another genre and being big and
getting big in that genre
and now you know your career is waiting
a little while now you're going to come
over the country that's always the donor
being the black guy when i came over in
2005 2006 there wasn't anybody on the
radio look like me for 25 years why
would i think that i'm going to come and
be the one who breaks down the barriers
again and and
you know well it's one thing to be like
i don't care i can listen to whatever i
want to the other kids but there's that
takes a whole other brand of courage a
whole other level of did it feel like it
required courage i mean did you find
yours did you have to steal yourself in
the face of some of this criticism or
whatever racist uh counter absolutely
something i said to myself i'll never
forget when uh
when that's when i went to nashville
have a meeting and got a real record
deal and i realized i had a real record
deal
i said to myself i can take anything
that happens to me right now because no
matter what happens to me it's not one
one
hundred one one thousands of what
happened to charlie pratt it's not even
gonna be close i mean no matter what
happens to me it can't be close to the
crap he had to go through
so i think i can handle it and i can
handle it with dignity in the way a man
will handle it had you been familiar
with his work and his path
oh i was a fan absolutely i've been a
fan since he-haul back in the 70s first
of all you know saw him on a hee haw and
went wow that's awesome you know and
then you know finding that charlie pride
album in my mom's collection still don't
know why and she told me she bought it
because he was black she'd never
listened to it because she bought it
part of the team if you support the team
exactly you know
but uh
it was you know i'd known him forever
and i and you know when you hear the
stories and you know the stories and you
and
and i i just know that nothing i could
have gone through was even would even be
close to what he liked well i i
yeah so i i'm sure you'd have you'd have
to remind yourself of that uh from time
to time yeah yeah
yeah
is it has that changed for that has that
gotten better darius i mean
i think
i think it's getting so much better in
country music i think country music is
lots of parts of countries are waking up
to itself not you know
not liking that stereotype anymore you
see you know like you see
so many guys getting record deals now
and having hits you know kane and jimmy
you know having these big hits and these
careers now that are you know jimmy's
going to be playing you know canes will
be playing stadium soon and
he'd love to see it and now you see
record labels instead of
throwing away
a cd or or something that got you know
in african-american they listen to it
because everybody wants to sign
everybody everybody wants to be more
inclusive yeah that's always a good
thing it's it is and and uh i know it's
it's also
you've done such a huge thing for
that genre of music which is obviously
so popular in this country i mean it's
like i know a lot of people who
who balk at even saying their country
fans because it it does have that stigma
of um well if you l if you like country
music you're it's like nascar or
something it means you're racist you're
it's it's inherent it's implied there's
an element of that implication that like
i'm
sure most country music fans are like
really wanting to see more diversity and
absolutely i think so because i think
country music fans are like pop music
fans are like they just want good songs
they want good songs and great singers
and personalities you know and
and give them that and that they'll
listen i know i you know i find that way
about i i i don't think i'm in the
minority i don't think i'm some like
really tolerant uh but i find that way
about any sort of art any comedy for for
sure is um i agree you know you're
making me laugh uh
i don't mean to diminish
the struggle that you must have had to
go through a as as a pioneer as somebody
who's following in charlie pride's
footsteps but i can't believe it was 20
years later you're right that's
25 25 wow it shocked me i didn't even i
didn't even think about that i mean i
knew i knew guys like trinity triggs or
reese palmer i thought would have had a
top 25 hit in country music
and when i when don't i don't think i'll
think about it in the top 25 somebody
said to me it's the first time in 25
years i was like wow wow
the top 25 wow oh my god oh my god
maybe
i i wonder how long uh
yeah i mean think thank god you think
like that it's it's funny so you talk
about racism and and well it's a problem
as a white person i i hear about it in
theory it's it's it's it's more of a
theoretical and
and it it really strikes me when i when
it's measured and it can be measured in
something like that oh yeah you know
absolutely
absolutely that's because there's no
other reason yeah there's no other
there's no other reason right
yeah well and and now they'll be um i
mean you've really opened the doors uh
it's
it's
it's it's funny it's brave what you did
but um i also keep thinking about it in
terms of you just
it's like you just like this music it
wasn't like yeah i'm gonna be a
crusader i
i really wasn't coming in trying to be
to break down the because i didn't think
i could yeah yeah i just wanted to make
the record i just wanted to make a
record i wanted to make i just wanted i
wanted to i wanted to sound like randy
foster and and so it was like
i'm glad that it turned out to be
something that that what it was but i
wasn't i really didn't expect it
[Music]
i'm doing a throwback voice because this
segment is brought to you by bud light
seltzer's new retro summer pack we grew
up in the 80s the 90s 80s 90s yeah and
when i think of like summer back then
what do you think
the start of the summer was the best yes
the kickoff memorial day weekend yes yes
because it's like the horizon is so
bright and like no school and we would
have a picnic in our neighborhood we
still go to this picnic occasionally as
justin just did yeah but things are a
little different now as adults because
now we can keep the good vibes going
with bud light seltzer and we do because
it's such a great summer drink i mean i
drink it year-round but i especially
like in the summer because it's
refreshing you're in the sun
it's a nice day drink it's 100 calories
five percent alcohol i mean you know who
doesn't like it and i like it with a
koozie yeah now they have something
called the limited edition bud light
seltzer retro summer pack and it's a
tie-dye pack which features three really
fun throwback flavors that reminds me of
summer's gone by of yesteryear yes
flavors like blue raspberry blue
raspberry was a fun flavor as a kid you
get your tongue all blue yeah summer ice
and cherry limeade those are the three
flavors yeah if that weren't exciting
enough and you know let's face it it is
but for the first time ever fans can
also purchase these outta sight flavors
in a new form with bud light seltzer
retro summer icicles so grab some
friends play some tunes
and enjoy the vibes get it delivered
right to your door find a retailer near
you at bud light.com delivery or pick it
up at your local neighborhood grocery
convenience or liquor store
hello
[Music]
i just want to go back a little to
your your days at university of south
carolina when you so you met your band
mates the the blowfish you met the other
bloke yeah
were you guys playing was it like a
college band were you playing in school
oh yeah we played college
and
we played everywhere you know we played
all over the southeast was that
difficult too i mean playing because
like
i remember hooting the blowfish coming
up during a time where there was there
was also a huge explosion in like
hip-hop and
and there was
and the alternative was like
it felt like a different world than
hip-hop um
did you have to face any of that back
back then was it absolutely yeah oh
absolutely oh i mean
that's that's one of those things i mean
there's never really been a moment that
i've been trying to do this where i
haven't activated because i was
i've never really
even the early days of playing clubs
with what people would say playing those
frat houses man
going and trying to play the play the ka
house presbyterian what is wrong with us
who would take that gig with black with
a black lead singer in 1988
that was stupid
was there ever a moment i mean how how
close did you you guys come to being
like ah maybe we should call this off or
was it ever addressed was it ever like
and and and and was there how like how
bad did it get i mean
it was a dress but you know it was also
addressed with the fact of knowing
there's five of us in a whole frat load
of them and we got to get our [ __ ] we
got to get our [ __ ] out of here
you know
and so and so you know it was it was
it's always been there it's never not
been a part of my career wow at what
point did it turn i mean at what point
did it become you are now bigger than
whatever that
whatever the [ __ ] is whatever the
occasional
opposition to to you being the lead
singer was
that's always been the case you know
that success is a word that you can
measure in so many different ways and
and for us for us back then
success was going to that bar we just
went to four times and played the five
people than 10 people then 20 people and
this time were sold out with a line out
back that was success
and success is always a good equalizer
you know you know and so
people could say what they want and
said i i never cared about that [ __ ] man
i just i just want to play music huh
that's
what uh it's amazing i mean again i keep
going back to your it sounds like your
mother was a huge influence in that
mindset and you're it sounds like you
had a really great upbringing in terms
of i mean
it's all planted there um
absolutely it's really cool uh
do you you must get sick of people um
because i look at you and i i know your
your work and i'm still tempted to call
you hootie sometimes
yes
do you get does that happen a lot to you
not even remotely as much as it used to
yeah i mean back you know back about
four five before everything started
taking over nashville it was
you know what happened
you know every year it happened yeah
a lot you know
you know and i you know i always
at that point i was just glad they still
knew who i was they could call me
anything they wanted that's right
you know
but uh it's pretty you know
i'm proud that uh
that we did something that was so
impactful that years from now people
still to yeah that didn't bother me of
course yeah um
and and now it's funny like that music
is that time
it's making me feel old because i the
other day i saw kids wearing like i
noticed that those fashion trends even
from the 90s or like
have you seen this it's like
re-emerging and i thought well i've
waited long enough i've i haven't like
you know i haven't changed my thoughts
so maybe i'll be cool again when um
does that is and i know that music is
really having a
a second life that
90s yeah i mean
the tour we did with barenaked ladies
was you know
shocking i mean i couldn't believe the
numbers we made
people were hungry for it and it was fun
and that was fun and that was the first
time you toured and released the new
album
hoodie and the blowfish album since 2019
i was i couldn't believe that was the
first time in 15 years i don't know
i couldn't either when i when i was said
i was like wow right right that's right
was it was it nice what did it feel like
to get back with the with the blowfish
it was great being out there you know
playing those songs and and just
i it was
to be doing it to be doing it at that
level with us you know 33 years
after we started this thing
it was it was awesome it was really
awesome and fun and
you know i hope the fans got got what
they paid for because we tried to bring
it up will you do it again you think
after this
is all over we'll do it sometime
you know i think when we decide the time
is right we'll do it again you know i
think we both we all realize you know
it's not our day jobs anymore so but you
know but we can get together and do it
every now and then and have fun with it
is it because so you had said they
didn't they were not wanting to is that
kind of what led to the tren your
transition they didn't want to it was
just the touring schedule it was just
not wanting to tour
just one of our guys said he didn't want
to be in a touring band anymore yeah and
we were banned you know i mean the three
of the four of us are banned it was like
never a moment where we were like let's
get a new drummer or whatever it is you
know it was like okay if you're out
we're done yeah you know we're not going
to just go get another blowfish
no yeah you can yeah you know and so we
didn't
there is where did that name come from
hooting the blowfish are you probably
sick of answering this but i i don't
know
i'm just an idiot because i when i named
the band i never thought
i never even and everything crossed my
mind people would call me hootie
and uh there was there was a two guys
i was i was singing in the show choir
called carolina live and there was these
two guys one guy uh
had really big big eyes and he wore
these round glasses and so he looked
kind of like an owl
so we started calling hoodie and
everybody started calling him hootie i
mean everybody
and his best friend
i was he sang but he was also a trumpet
player you know he could do the dizzy
gillespie thing where he blew up his
cheeks
you know yeah and so he looked like a
blowfish and so i started i called
started calling the blowfish everybody
started calling this and i'll never
forget we're sitting in myrtle beach
at something we were singing at and they
walk into my room i have the party in my
room and they walk in and i say i look
at them and i go hey who do you blow
fish
and somewhere in my mind i lied to
myself and said what a great name for a
band
[Laughter]
i it's so funny darius i do that a lot
i'm like or whatever it is some i think
about that naming a band it's got to be
really hard so i think that'd be great
i find myself doing that like uh oh look
at that that pine cone just falling pine
cones
that feels a good name
i just came to me
but i so you you say you regret it one
because
it's funny it's now to me sounds so much
like a band but at the time
i imagine only because you guys are so
popular but i now i imagine
at the time it was like
were they resistant to that being the
name was that like and were the other
blowfish like well wait a minute hooty
and the blowfish we sat down and tried
to rename it like before like when i
said that a drama a guitar player like
okay whatever and then we sat down one
day and we tried to come up with a
better name for a man and we actually
the bass player came up with black and
blue
because i was a black guy and they all
had blue eyes i was like no we're not
going to go with that
that's bad
it would have to be black and blues i
guess but then that would sound like a
blues band
exactly so uh but we didn't come up with
a better name you said you didn't think
people call you hootie but then you know
i mean hindsight is 20 20 i guess but
like
but it's like i'm thinking and not to
judge your band naming skills at the
time but it was like well what do you
expect i mean like it's one guy it's the
singer and it's like buddy holly and the
crickets it's like i know i'm an idiot i
know
i know
i mean you're absolutely right i know
you don't get it anymore but for a while
you probably did deserve the hootie
calls the hootie hoots
i got it a lot dude i deserved it you're
right i deserve it but but it's also
funny darius that like it was the
impulse was kind of
it it was like a funny thing that you
noticed about these guys it was like
kind of teasing in a teasing way
the thing was whether you liked it or
not you never forgot if that's true
that's true you know that was that was
that was a plus in the long run yeah
that's the mark of a great name i guess
yeah that's it especially when you're
like trying to i mean there's so much
music going on then i mean it was such
an explosion
yeah the grunge and the whatever yeah
but that that like you want to really
differentiate yourself you want to do
whatever you can probably
yeah absolutely and i mean we didn't
think about it that way but it really
turned out it really worked that way of
course
how quickly did it happen there is like
how quickly after you guys formed and
and grew as a college band we were
banned for like seven or eight years
before we got a record deal
and then uh we got a record deal i guess
our record was out for probably
four or five months before anything
happened before like anything happened
and then the letterman show happened
when lettering happened it all changed
isn't that amazing that's like
well for our younger listeners uh
that that's a different time i know
i know they'll be like well why should
you just put it on youtube or uh
youtube yeah isn't that funny i know
like those shows they could really make
or break and that's what made it so the
stakes were so high for so many of those
artists i remember those that's why
those performances were like
uh
really great those late show oh
absolutely i mean i mean
those those
those shows were like
were like youtube or whatever except you
know that you only see it once yeah yeah
and
but the thing is for us
once was all it took because once we i
mean we played that show on a friday and
by the next monday it was it was all
changing you could feel the change
really
and what form does that take as a band
um what's the first thing
the first thing was all of a sudden
you're getting these reports from your
label you know you got 20 ads this week
you have 50 ads you know you got you
know
that that was
a total different thing for us because
because everybody was still playing
grunge nobody was no pop station or rock
station was trying to play this hold my
hand you know
and
and then all of a sudden they work oh
man i i remember that i mean i was in
high school i remember it was like
that song explode it was it's funny i'm
thinking about it now it was you're
right i mean i i just as an audience as
somebody like in the world taking in
your
your music i remember it going from it
was just everywhere like yeah and i was
always listening to the radios right
when i started to drive and it was
god man it was it felt like
i can't imagine be going through that
like what that must have
been like on the other end but i
remember thinking like dad they're
everywhere now you couldn't get away you
couldn't get away from it i'll never
forget one time one time we pulled up
and we pulled up into some city and we
get into
a van somebody's driving us in the van
to the venue
and
[Applause]
we got the radio on and one of our songs
come down
so i turn the channel
and there's the next channel there's a
different one of ourselves oh wow weird
i turn the channel again and on the
third station was a different one of
ours oh my god that's and we just
we just started laughing
we just started laughing i mean you
couldn't get away from it yeah you
couldn't get away from wow that's
amazing i
and and you know a thing that comes up a
lot is certainly in my life but but when
i talk to people about that moment
where where things like that started
happening
uh
it's i i and you had mentioned your mom
a couple times and she seems like she
seemed like she was such a huge force
in your life she really shaped you um
did she get to
did she get to witness that i mean did
you get to share that with people
not at all no no it was probably three
years she died about three years ago i'm
sorry yeah i'm sorry to hear that
i'm sorry i know she inspired some songs
um oh yeah
yeah tons of songs about where i got
first record yeah i'm sorry to hear that
and you had also said that you wrote a
song about your dad but it was released
in europe
because
you thought he wouldn't hear it was that
it
yeah
yeah did he
did he ever hear it why were you afraid
of him hearing it
because i'm such a nice guy even though
he was such a jerk i was such a nice guy
i didn't want to hurt anybody's feelings
but uh i don't know if he heard it or
not we never really talked like that
i don't really know yeah wow
isn't that funny that a lot of i i
talked to a musician about this that you
can write something it can come from
such a personal place you know it's
there's something so revealing and like
intimate about
that process of writing
out your feelings really
and then it's just consumed by
i mean like you said you're flipping the
channels on a radio it's consumed by
people who are
late to work or annoyed with oh yeah
it's
wild
it's crazy when you really look at it it
is
because i know what music means to me
and so so whenever i think about a song
i wrote or
meaning something like that to somebody
else it's overwhelming because i know
what it means to me i bet but then
people will transcribe they'll you know
they'll put whatever feelings they have
onto it it'll speak to them in some way
yes
i love that i i bet i bet that must
especially when you're doing it live it
must be a
a really special
feeling i i can't imagine to to really
like connect with strangers like that oh
man there's nothing like singing a song
some love song or some sad song live and
you look down and you see somebody
crying yeah because you know you touched
this you're touching this person's soul
with that moment yeah it's a beautiful
thing you've been a part of lives i mean
just for me i mean i'm a stranger too
well not anymore we're now we're very
good friends but uh absolutely
um
like hold my hand i have direct
he said this is some of the hootie songs
i have such close it was such a great
time in my life it was that i have there
are touchstones you know there are
moments that mark
when i a song when i hear one now i
immediately get
become happy my friend of mine we were
just in um carolina beach and
we went to uh there's like a nostalgia
like an 80s shop
and uh
and we walked in and we were like oh my
god they're nintendo lunch boxes and
light brights and like we were just like
instantly giddy you know and uh yeah and
we said to the proprietor we said um
is this we are we being weird is like
does this happen uh and he said they
said all the time people your age like
oh so i'm now imagining your shows your
especially when you're now the tour in
2019 with with the blowfish that i i i
bet you felt that like exponentially
oh yeah you felt it because you look out
the audience and you see it
you know you see you see those folks
who are out there and
they're they're reliving those times you
know those are living those times in 94
95 96 when they heard that song with
their best friend
you know and it's it's beautiful to be a
part of that to be a part of people's
lives that way that's right
it's really cool well yeah i mean i
thank you for those moments in my life
um
and and i also i i was
thank you for this you do a lot of
charity work um for underprivileged kids
now uh
why is that
particularly important to you is is it
as simple as
you know you grew up there i mean you
know what that's like and you just
giving it absolutely yeah
i mean that was something embedded in me
also about my mom you always help people
you know
less
not less fortunate so much just help
people if you can help somebody help
them
and so for me
if my celebrity or or me coming and
playing a song can help some charity
raise a lot of money i'll sign a guitar
for that you know
you know
also for me
like you said i've been there
i'm not going to ask my mom for 40 bucks
to go to camp because i know
we don't have 40 bucks all my friends
are going but i i i'm not gonna go you
know i've been there and so when i can
help with little things like that little
just help a kid
be happy for a second i'm in a minute
that's really cool um darius what is the
name of the is there something we can
talk about uh we can let people know
about you know there's a couple of
orphanages i help a lot there's a
children's hospital in charleston that
i'm on the board and that's really
important to me
because we because we're trying to you
know st jude's you know saying jews
helping all these kids and nobody ever
gets a bill that's amazing to me
we give them a lot of little charities i
like to like like some like like
patterson's academy in charleston which
is a great school for
for severely handicapped kids then
that's some place for them to go every
day just like a regular school
and i i mean a place like that you can't
help but help yeah that's great terry's
um
it's really good to hear and and what we
want to talk about that because we we
like you know it's it's not much of a
platform but it's uh it is technically
one that we have so we like to use it
wisely um yeah you you just released
your latest single my masterpiece it was
a follow-up to beers and sunshine i'm
not telling you this i'm hoping you know
this you you're aware of this
i heard about that okay yeah
but you i found this
you wrote it over it was
both written over zoom how did you do
that what was that process like it's
basically like what we're doing right
now except you sit around with guitars
or or a track or something and uh the
funny thing about beers of sunshine was
not only was that written over zoom but
it was all recorded over soon i don't
know because when we were
we recorded it there was no studios open
and like it was right there at the
beginning of the everything was closed
down nobody was even taking a chance and
coming into the studio so yeah we wanted
to get a song out we had to all do it
over over over the computer and it was
awesome darius it's really kind of you
to not judge me for that last question
because i'm now realizing how um how
stupid it was
what's it like to do it over zoom it's
kind of like this
kind of like this
[Laughter]
don't get me wrong i hate it i i'd much
rather get back in the room with the
guys and write but uh but it worked for
this record i know likewise i know even
for this it's like uh
this is
you know this is great i love getting to
see you here and we're safe and all that
but um yeah there's there's no real
substitute for uh
being in a room together yeah absolutely
absolutely um do you do you know if
there are any plans for uh touring i
mean are you starting to see light at
the end of this tunnel oh yeah i mean i
got two shows next week oh
hey oh i got it yeah i got a warm-up
show in charleston and then uh i think
myrtle beach is gonna be like 40 000
people oh my god
so you know they're starting back up
everybody's out i'm not going to really
i want to do pairs of festivals this
summer but i'll tour in the winter i
think oh cool uh you have a family you
have kids
yeah i got three awesome kids man yeah
they're awesome yeah they're awesome
that's yeah that's great they come to
the show i mean they must see you play
they do they don't care they couldn't
care less it's not you know it's a
social
it's a social event for them
they're not coming to see they're not
coming to see daddy play
and if i say something they'll all let
me know dad we've seen a lot of shows
well
you know it's it's funny i i stopped my
dad was a teacher and uh i stopped going
to his office and the novelty wore off
at a certain point um
yeah i guess it's i mean for them it's
just
they they bring their friends because
their friends want to come ah get over
sure they use they're not coming to see
it yeah oh absolutely yeah i'm gonna i'm
an excuse for a party that's all i have
yeah that's not a bad thing to be though
no i love them i'm good with it
well there's it was a challenging
because you again like your mom keeps
coming up i keep thinking about her now
because she seems like just you seem
like you have so much light and
uh
it sounds like it came from her
was it difficult um raising them because
they then grew up in a totally different
environment
um they grew up without having things
that you didn't have was it did you have
a hard time
you know raising them the way you were
raised which was like sounds like
the right way you know and um with this
right this mentality of like giving back
and
and being grateful and uh was that
difficult because
just just economically they're in a
different position well i got lucky
they're moms
are you know are great like
my wife was great raising good you know
and she kept them really grounded i mean
and when you have some when you have
somebody helping you like that a partner
it's easy to keep the ground like you
know when when you say yes and they say
no
you know and that worked
great i mean and
because like you said you know growing
up the way i grew up you know
it was great to have another perspective
and to
raise them to be good healthy fun
people who care who with empathy who
care about others you know that and
that's that's i would say that about all
my kids that's really nice that's that's
kind of like that's what the show should
all be about i should you know that's
like what you hope for in life
absolutely
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
i just have a uh a lightning round if
you don't mind if you like all right
absolutely okay absolutely uh number one
who is your favorite child
no i'm kidding i'm kidding oh my
goodness goodness gracious
they do that all the time
yeah i'm one of three too we used to
tease our parents about that um
uh what did you do what is your most
commonly used they're gonna love this
question what's your most commonly used
emoji would you say
i don't emoji ever never like i will
like i i will actually put like i'll put
a parenthesis and like i'll put middle
finger emoji parentheses i won't ever i
don't use emojis at all
but in what context would you do that
middle finger emoji with the paper you
know you know you know if somebody's
like somebody's making fun doing
something funny and making funny and you
put up a middle finger emoji i will put
the emoji i'll put all the words middle
finger emoji all right
okay oh oh i got you okay
um
even with your kids how your kids are
probably firing them not even i think
there's a blowfish emoji
they want me to so bad and i refuse to
use emojis they want me to so bad like
if i slip up it's the greatest thing
that's ever happened
oh man okay yeah i isn't there a bloke
no now that i think about it maybe there
is there's a book there's a book there
is a blowfish you've never used the
blowfish emoji
no whether it'd be very scenic yeah
[Laughter]
i've seen it i bet
uh speaking of blowfish um what is are
you a sushi guy
uh yes
and what's your go-to
uh what what would be your go-to order
i like the california roll a lot i like
anything with the tuna the tuna
yeah like anything with tuna um yeah uh
i'm pretty easy to get i mean i don't
want any octopus or anything like that
but you know i'll try anything else is
the octopus because you saw the
documentary
no that the documentary would would keep
you free either no but no it's so gay
it's too chewy
yeah well
if people say that about blood now and
you keep thinking about blood
so you've never tried blowfish i've
never tried the blowfish that scares me
i think that would that'd be how i would
go uh that was somebody would i would
just get a little piece and i would go
i want you to be old and like have done
everything i want your kids to have kids
but uh there'd be something sort of like
hilariously ironic about that that would
be so perfect
um
what is if you could be a professional
athlete you were talking about the
dolphins do you like any other miami
teams or it was just that moment no just
the dolphins just the dolphins yeah
still still because i'm a chess fan so
we're
we're you know we're division
right yes we are both long suffering
we both suck a lot
yeah i wish you had kept uh adam gays
well you i'm glad you guys got it yeah
we're good i like coach k but you guys
yeah good for you guys yeah and it's am
i who now is it uh
oh tua right it's
yeah cool
yeah great what do you think didn't they
draft a quarterback
no we didn't we we we uh you're sticking
with twitter
okay yeah we're going tour do you go to
games
yes yeah yes
yes
absolutely and do people assume you're a
dolphins fan because of the marine
connection to the blowfish
yes yes they usually think yeah
yeah
yeah but you know people are funny about
that
that's always funny i bet i i'm thinking
because like
then now back that those great teams you
mentioned larry zankind bob griese i
remember the um
god how great were those receivers when
they had mark clayton oh um yeah oh my
goodness
yeah greatest teams never win the super
bowl yeah
absolutely um if you could have one
snack food for the rest of your life
what would it be
oh good almond joy i'm enjoy
i'm enjoy
i love it though
like ice cream is like dessert food
that's not like snack right
no no i'm in choice
snack i think like we have to amend this
question maybe i'm thinking something
you you're just tuned out maybe you're
stuck you know whatever you're watching
some movie and you're just popping that
would yeah that would be popcorn of
course i mean i just love to sit down
and eat popcorn yeah like like that's
the only really snack food i eat
i don't get a lot of chips or anything
like that yeah if you love almond joy so
much is it when you have a mounds is it
like disappointing do you begrudgingly
do it or do you do or do not do it at
all because it's like oh man i i don't
even want
i i know what this could be
i'll eat a mound
but it's not an almond joy hot i agreed
um if you could be a professional
athlete what would it what sport golf oh
i'd play football football football no
doubt about it yeah did you play in high
school
i played up until high school when i was
13 i i'd love to tell the story i was 13
i was going to try a football practice
first day and i walked up to practice
and i looked at the field and i saw a
whole bunch of guys that we had all
played most of us had grown up together
playing little league football who was
always on different teams you know
always on different teams like we had
like 10 teams in this little thing and i
go and i look and they're all on the
same field and i really realize that was
the day i realized i wasn't going to
play in the nfl and so i turned around
and went home
[Laughter]
what is your size
yeah my size of my speed i had no speed
okay all right yeah well no
not gonna happen you were smart darius i
was really tiny i'm sure i was smaller
than you and i at 13 too i might it was
the first year my mom said okay you can
try out and i did and it was um
it was a disaster i this was
going to high school i was 89 pounds i i
was 4 foot 10.
wow yeah and i and i did i stuck with it
um but this is not about me this is
about you uh
what is your when your kids were little
when uh what was a movie that you really
wanted to introduce you were like
excited to introduce them to
oh goodness
and they didn't like it it's uh it's the
one i got
my all-star my i need i need prevagen so
i can remember stuff like this so the
disney movie with kurt i think kurt
russell with a with a horse kicks the
field goals
uh um what is that one cause i remember
i showed it
yeah remember i showed it to my two
youngest kids and they just didn't like
it at all
i was like i couldn't wait for them to
ah yeah and they just didn't like it oh
i'm dreading that darius i'm dreading
like something that i find so sacred
that's so special to me
it was like my favorite disney movie
whenever they showed it i was so excited
i wanted my kids to see it they didn't
like ironically they're like we just
wanna watch funny nevo
um exactly well what's what is your
go-to do you ever sing karaoke i always
wonder this
one song walking in memphis only song
i'll do karaoke really
what now why is that
that song was put on the earth for me to
sing ah yeah it's just it's exactly
where i want to be as as a singer the
words are great the melody's great
yeah oh i bet i could i bet you i can
hear you singing that that sounds yeah i
bet you really kill that um
and what and and are people ever
disappointed are they like i'm sure
people try to get you to sing your own
songs at karaoke always yeah always yeah
and i always never no no
no
even if your kids ask
no yeah
they would never have they know dad's
rule if they would be horrified if i
tried to oh i bet i yeah they would be
horrified
i bet uh do you ever i'm sure you've had
this experience you've heard somebody
singing your songs
oh yeah yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah and they and they think they're
killing it too
they think they're like they're whitney
houston up there singing that song you
know
yeah absolutely
who was your who was your first
celebrity crush oh krista mcnichol
christy mcnichol oh no kidding yeah
okay uh i'm thinking of a a summer camp
movie little foxy yes yes yes with uh
with uh that with tatum o'neill uh table
neal yeah yes that's that's the one yes
that's the one okay wow great
[Laughter]
his hat just flew off his head that's
the movie that made me yeah that was my
crush movie absolutely so funny my i
mean i i my age my former agent my
friend abby bluestone if you're
listening was in that movie she played
um
now how would you say is this
because i think she would say i don't
know that she'd be hurt by this because
now she is no longer but she was a
i don't want to say overweight child but
she was the kind of
wrote it's really what how why would you
say that i want you to get married i
don't know i'm gonna let you i'm gonna
let you say that
i'm gonna let you i'm letting you handle
that okay yeah it's smart
smart you've done these before
uh darius would you say chunky um
so chunky okay uh
um
if you had to get a tattoo i don't know
if you have any but if you had to get
another one
uh what would you get i'm getting one
more i'm getting uh i'm trying to find
i'm trying to get some an artist to
write out
my kids names like in elvish because i
think the elvish writing from the from
the from the lord from the token books
yeah so it's such a beautiful
like way of writing i i would really
like like like i'd give my kids that
their names tattooed that's not really
you know darius that's like an
interesting combination of
really beautiful and heartfelt and and
nerdy
yeah totally geeky yeah absolutely yeah
it's great i love it it's my favorite
combination
that's really cool yes that'd be me
what is your what is your favorite fruit
oh pineapple i love pineapple yeah oh i
can eat them 24 hours a day i love them
oh yeah yeah too much yeah yeah
got it i haven't had a good pineapple in
a while that's uh it's a good reminder
um who would you want to play you in
your in the darius rucker story the your
biopic
uh
great question
michael b jordan oh
hell of an actor and but but he's gonna
play the young me denzel's got to play
with me at this stage though
i would like to see that actually
uh
yeah that'd be a great combination um
and they would do you justice who is
your favorite simpsons character oh
another great question because i love
this show so much yeah who's my favorite
simpsons character like i mean i know
homer's like sort of the obvious nelson
now still doubt nelson
because nelson's got such a big heart he
just shows it to you very solidly
yes that's true
well nelson
also it's nelson is um that's such a
good example of like the same joke
um that's been done i mean god how many
episodes now but over 30 whatever years
but it's still always funny it's like
always yes
yeah it's making fun of the bully
yes oh i agree what a good call you're
my favorite yeah darius great call you
know it's not now that i think about it
i i think i'd like michael b jordan to
play me in my biopic too
i think he did he's that good he's that
versatile
i'm great do you prefer dogs or cats
dogs i like cats but for dogs yeah
um do you have any
i do i have a dog called mochi she's a
little i don't like a cockatoo or
something she's a small dog but i love
her mochi's got to be a small dog
yeah i got another dog named shula
is
yeah yeah uh do you prefer the beatles
of the rolling stones
love the rolling stones so much but i'm
a beatles guy yeah love the stone but
the beatles are the the beatles are most
important entity in the history of music
to me do you remember listening did your
mom listen to them in the house
i remember you know i was talking about
the wi-fi i remember being about five or
six and finding
245's in the collection of music and it
was the beatles
and it i mean they are i they're the
most important thing do you remember
which is now music do you remember which
it was the first two singles it was uh
she loves you yeah yeah yeah
please please please please me yes oh
man yeah if you were to cover one one of
them uh at your next show in myrtle
beach if i can play any beatles thought
i'd play hey jude uh yeah but you can't
you know you can't i just you know you
can't just be playing hey jude
yeah
that's a really funny quote
you can't just be playing it's true i
mean i think true you know i was just
talking to my friend about hey jude and
as obviously
i'm not [ __ ] on it
if anyone is easily triggered by
anything remotely negative about the
beatles i love the beatles turn this off
right now but the end of hey jude
does it not go on a little too is it not
like hey oh absolutely i mean
it does it's
but your version you could not do that
or do your version will be shorter yeah
yeah that would be shorter nobody wants
to hear me sing that long anyway
that's not true um and and would you say
ketchup or mustard
ketchup yeah
are you are you a barbecue guy do you do
you uh i mean south charlotte yeah i
love barbecue we i love both baits i
love mustard and
tomato base barbecue
and vinegar-based barbecue i like boys
so you okay
do you douse it oh i love wall i love
barbecue yeah um well i you're probably
in a great area for that uh
man charleston i'm excited for you i'm
excited for for
when is the new album oh my it was just
released my masterpiece this thing will
just came out
i'll be out the ball i think we've got a
date yet in the fall okay and uh people
can find you on
speaking of on social media uh i'm on
all of them berries.com
you know i'm on all of them yeah well i
can't wait for the new music because um
i i'm a fan of yours and this was
this was so enjoyable thank you i
enjoyed it thank you just had a really
good time oh good likewise thanks all
right good luck in the tournament
thank you take care all right see ya bye
[Music]
so that happened
oh god i just got like
it's rare when you feel
chills down the front of your body
usually i get them down my back
that was cause that was one of the only
front kills
maybe because it was so immediate it hit
you that it didn't have time to like
move anywhere else oh i just had like a
i just doubled over and awkward
um wow so that just happened yeah then
that happened too oh my god uh sorry i
think this is
well over a hundred shows now and that
was
far the most uncomfortable i've felt
oh my god this squeaky chair it's also
we've been talking about the squeegee
for 30 episodes you have more more you
think oh this chair has been squeaking i
think since day one
it's gotten squeakier
why don't we just do something about it
i know how do we just grab the bull by
the horns why can't we take a page out
of darius rucker's playbook have a
singular goal in life
since he was four years old wanted to be
a musician and he did it
against all the odds oh the odds that we
can never comprehend i mean i can
comprehend it yeah can you fully i can
understand it i can't i haven't lived it
yeah but like but i can imagine what
he's gone and now it's semantics i don't
know what the right word is you can't
you can't empathize
no i can sympathize though yes to
overcome that it's like hard enough i
would imagine to
make any headway in in any musical genre
yeah but but like country mute like well
i mean he said he he said it best when
he he said um
you know when he was in hooting the
blowfish and then when he was a country
singer
he he got backlash on
in both ways in both genres backlash
blacklash um and he said uh people would
think what are you doing here or you
don't belong here yeah so what are you
doing here yeah you're you're an
african-american
front man of a
and the rest of the members are white of
a rock and roll band that didn't happen
it was always the opposite it was always
a white man would be the front man and
the backup band were black that's true
african-american
um so that was unusual
and then to be an african-american
country star now
it it he's he's overcome so much well
it's interesting too because like so
often uh white acts would appropriate
black music black performers i mean like
look albus presley i mean it happened
throughout the 50s and 60s um and in
this case it's like
yeah he's kind of entering this
much whiter musical
arena i mean
almost strictly white i didn't realize
that 25 years that's crazy
it's but the top 20 but i think the only
reason
he's or the main reason i would guess is
that he's been able to overcome all this
is because he wasn't trying to overcome
anything exactly yeah it was just about
the music that was right and he's got a
very like
simple nonchalant um way of seeing it
like i just i just want to play music
well i like that i bet that's been
coming up in
uh life in conversations about the
simplicity of uh our existence and
relationships and what drives us
i think a lot of that can be distilled
or should be distilled to a
a more pure drive like that a simple
drive like i just like the music or
you're in a relationship it's like you
can talk about the ins and outs and what
makes it work but it's like
maybe you just like somebody's company
you just want somebody maybe it's that
simple yeah and and i think that's what
keeps i think maybe that's what uh kept
him on that track kept him driven what
do you mean i like the music why do i
have to stop well also clearly he
was raised the right way wow by his mom
and he um
i i you know there's not even he seems
so down to earth to the point where
like there's not even a whiff of
celebrity
right
he just seems like a totally i know
regular
guy i know you know some people talk
about they advertise how like a lot of
celebrities i've heard that to how down
to earth and they'll give examples of
their down-to-earthness and like their
humility but like yeah there there were
moments that were subtle with him and
which
completely
um
illustrated that
and one i'm thinking of is uh a kind of
a big one i guess is
is how game he was to kind of laugh
about the hootie thing yes you know like
yes and you you tested it well well
because i grew so comfortable with him
because he was
he seemed just so honestly like okay
with it well after he it was a really
funny story how did i never knew that
the band was named after he told that
whole story you continued to refer to
them as the blowfish
after finding out that he wasn't hoodie
and they weren't blowfish i know but it
still is you can't not you can't not put
those you cannot
well wha that's the maybe i mean i've
thought of him as hoodie since i was
like 14 years old but that's the pro if
you want to call it a problem that's the
issue with the name with it being a
band's name because right one hootie is
a singular thing of course and then i
mean you said it to him and you're right
he asked for it and he seemed like you
said totally fine totally fine which is
also like and he
i remember uh hooting the blowfish at
some point for no good reason uh
becoming kind of like
a a punchline in that they were i think
just because they got so big and it was
it's kind of a fun it's a funny name
hootie and the blowfish but there was um
and they were so popular i mean anything
that popular at a certain point by like
snarky hipster culture will become fire
of course and you're right it's it's a
funny name it's like a silly name
and a memorable like he said a memorable
name which is i think it makes it a good
name yeah yeah hootie hooting the
blowfish i wonder if
those the two that he was inspired by
the guy who with the glasses and
the owl and then the alley guy and the
dizzy glass v
um i wonder if they they know that
and that they were they ever sued him
for the rights
it's like oh wait i'm hoodie yeah and
these he's
it's a funny idea these two like
awkward guys who like never made much of
their lives yeah try to sue hooting the
blowfish for the rights to their name
that's really funny but they were like
kind of pretentious musicians like look
down on music like hooting the blowfish
uh but they yeah needed the
the capital that's funny it is funny i
don't know if it's a feature
maybe it's just a thing to talk about in
the podcast title darius rucker project
yeah
hootie if hootie's like oh and if he
does know or if the blowfish knows do
they
is that like a badge of hot do they talk
about that
if they know i'm sure they still talk
about it i bet they know hey you know
that band who it's like a fun story no
one believes them oh my god that would
be the end it's true that if you told it
at a bar you know like kind of drunk
it'd be like well
because the song will come on eventually
if you're at a bar long enough a hoodie
in the blowfish song come on and if the
guy who
who was inspired the
name is like all right by the way
you jesus i don't
really want to be with you [ __ ] i'm
hoodie i'm like the original oh my god
imagine all the time he said all the
times he's heard people sing his songs
oh my god he said it in a way that was
actually also because darius rucker has
a unique
sound style yeah
and so to sing one of those songs not
only are most people not as good of
singer as singer of singers but they
like try to emulate
that sound yes and then it becomes like
a caricature i've heard people do like
caricature
karaoke versions of hooting the blowfish
yeah i know that his voice was even in
like there were a lot of acts that
that's how big they were they were that
he inspired i think a way of like creed
like guards like her i don't know that's
something he should brag about well
another hugely successful bet that's
true but hooting the blowfish was so
much better no no i know but like i'm
saying he his to make it uh during a
time that you know he described as it
was all grunge it was like a very
specific
type of music to make it with that
unique a sound a voice and to be that
popular with that different a voice
that's true which is why god damn how
much do you want to hear him sing
walking in memphis now oh my god i
when he said that that was his go-to
karaoke song i immediately thought
that's perfect for him i know and then
he said uh something like
like the universe wrote that song for me
yeah yeah which is like sounds like an
arrogant thing to say but when you're as
down to earth as he is
it it just seems like yeah that's of
course that's true that's true and like
he knows he's that
modesty has been coming up more and more
right now and there's nothing in my life
and there's nothing worse than false
modesty i know i gotta i gotta why i've
been i've been noticing
yeah he knows he's good you know both
have to be more aware of false modesty
in the world but i to the point where
like i'm now more aware of i want to be
because i'm mindful of that of my own
you know like accepting a compliment is
is hard we have been talking about this
too i'm afraid i'm gonna go the rest of
my life with that being hard yeah i bet
it's like i think it's very difficult to
change that stuff feels so deeply rooted
in me i mean i shouldn't give up but
yeah um i think that's hard to change i
mean getting back to his childhood he
was raised with very little materially
but he looks back fondly on those times
and
consequently
now that he has all this money
he's not into spending a lot of money
you know cars and well because he fancy
things those weren't value exactly yeah
that was really interesting he's
maintained his like what he was raised
with and i think
for better or worse
we've maintained a lot of what we were
raised with well that's why i was trying
to ask him about um his kids like how
how do you raise your kids with that
mentality in in that pure way about um
non-materialistic way that yeah it's
funny that his kids aren't into his guys
i know
but i thought that about wilmer
valderrama woman yeah similar yeah they
reminded me of of one another yeah
you tried to relate to them by saying
that when we were kids we would
get excited to go see our father's
office yeah and then the luster is gonna
wore off a little bit yeah and it's such
a funny comparison i know to go to a
professor's office i know but it was
exciting i had a hoodie in the blowfish
concert i know i know but in terms of
like a kid through a kid's eyes that's
what you do i knew yeah and i remember
like i didn't want to get into it with
him because already it was a it was a
pretty strained comparison but i i did
made me think about like how cool it was
that pocket just like have any pen
remember those boxes of pens i love yes
oh no it's the uh in his secretary's
yeah his the whole philosophy department
had yeah uh
yeah and you'd go and remember her
office she had pads like all these
notepads oh my god yeah and i could just
you just take whatever you wanted like
notebooks i remember being thrilled by
that erasers paperclips yeah it was like
a cornucopia yeah it was you're like a
kid in a candy store you were like a kid
in a it's so funny
you're like a nerd in a stationery store
that's funny
oh man i felt like a nerd in a
stationary store
i i haven't thought about that in
decades but i god i love that yeah i
love those pens um you know it i thought
it was and i may be reading too much
into this but it's interesting that he
picked
as his favorite simpsons character
nelson i know because i first of all we
haven't heard that yet on the show but
also
it's like the grown-up version of nelson
i bet he's encountered a lot in his yes
in his you know oh yeah struggles with
people like how people treat him the
music industry well and i'm sure he's
encountered such like gross cartoonish
versions of that type of guy that type
of bully
that he has internalized it i mean
that's such a great way to look at boys
to like laugh at them the absurdity of
them being like
you because there's something
so childish about a grown-up about a
bully a grown-up bully who that but
that's what he how he described him yeah
he was like he's got a good heart but i
know he's got a good heart i would never
have described nelson that way but he
must have had to and again i'm probably
like speaking out of turn because i i
don't know the inner workings of his
brain what he's been through but it
seems possible
that he's internalized that character in
that way as a way of survival it's it's
pure compassion yeah it's so funny you
picked up on this interesting i know but
he does and nelson's damage too like
that's the other thing about that
character you can see
sometimes they'll show like his parents
or whatever you can see the vulnerable
yeah yeah yeah and yeah
wow that was a really interesting answer
let's read a letter okay
i only want to read with you
[Music]
this is from andrew hootingsworth
hooting's worth yeah weird no i'm
kidding
guys i can't believe i fell for that
idiot andrew brown
subject is
justin should listen to jane goodall
uh-oh oh oh i think it's more like her
advice
we'll see okay i'm scared
hi christian and justin my name's aj
ah and i live in indianapolis a.j is
that interesting to go by initials as a
who does oh the watt brothers i think of
like jj
and one is named uh was dj yeah but
people made fun of him because of dj
tanner and full house and he changed it
to
tj yeah which is dj to tj which a if
you're gonna go if you wanna departure
from dj why go to tj which sounds so
close to dj why don't i go zj or because
zj's not the gj the name the name that
people go by
and pj is little cutesy pj is cutesy pj
harvey that's right pj harvey's cool
though cool uh woman yeah but that's a
cool it shouldn't be a difference
no
uh my name is aj and i live in
indianapolis tough name for me to say
thanks a lot
that was not that was me uh back to
andrew hey justin mentioned once that he
had a nice time in indianapolis when he
was here for a convention i did so
thanks for that
uh you even have a cap to prove it yes
from the that jesse eisenberg has as
well right iu
yeah the friend of the show jesse
eisenberg that's right with the same cap
we were very randomly he was i missed
that guy
he was a great guest i wonder what he's
up to
um uh and back to andrew you're welcome
back anytime thanks andrew aj right
oh yeah aj he prefers yeah we said the
whole thing about that
um
aj says firstly i want to tell you i'm a
big fan thank you christian you have one
of the best podcast voices in the biz
thank you there you go the podcast biz
yeah you know it's fine we were just
talking about that about what accepting
a compliment
it was hard for me i know you i
hesitated you squirmed a little bit i
did
well i could in your way in a very
subtle way yeah but thank you that's
really nice i'm going to repeat it
christian you have one of the best
podcast voices in the pizza and i love
listening to it
that's very nice justin i love you it's
very nice
it's really nice what about me
justin i love your impressions and i
wish the show had even more of them oh
thank you aj
i don't know who that was oh that was
someone there was a loose it was a sort
of a beetle it was yeah that's right it
was ringo right it was not yeah but that
yeah ringo was it was probably more like
this is ringo well thank you
okay secondly he used to like all the
impressions yeah ringo you have to push
your
ringo to do ringo probably the fad you
look weird i know i know you gotta like
push you
push my i have to push my tiny chin into
my tiny neck
[Music]
that's a good cherry
back to andrew aj
secondly i think you should listen to
the advice from dr jane goodall and give
vegetarianism a try i totally agree aj
god that keeps coming up i've been
enjoying a veg lifestyle for 10 years
and thanksgiving is still my favorite
holiday ah
don't confuse it with veganism
exclamation point that's some different
[ __ ] another exclamation point i'm
talking about roasted veggie mac and
cheese another exclamation point black
bean and mango quesadillas that sounds
good [ __ ] green curry
these are all exclamation points
so much bomb food
bomb.com why would you eat a fish or a
cow but not a beloved turtle it's true
just try it frozen who says you don't
eat turtles i mistakenly had turtle soup
once i don't want to talk about it okay
one week and you can make a huge
lifestyle change that's way better for
the environment whack a flak of flame
did it and he's a badass who
wait
i i i thought it was
i feel like i just lost my mind for a
second
or aj did um whack a fact whack a flack
of flame i gotta look that up uh-huh
whack-a-flack of flame probably
i'll bet your whack-a-flack of flame is
insanely popular whacka like whacka come
on like whack-a-mole uh no it's actually
not like whack-a-mole it's w-a-c-k-a
isn't whack with an h right whack uh oh
he's gonna come right up
oh he's the first wacka
it's actually pronounced it's actually a
spell is it he or she uh it's ahi it's
w-a-k-a one k w a oh he oh aj you're big
you're not as big a whack of flack of
flame as you whack a flocka fame it's
f-l-o-c-k-a
flame wow
aj was a whack-a-flack of flaming
splaining to me joaquin james mulfers
whoa born may 31st 1986 known
professionally as walka flock of fame is
an american rapper and actor ah i
figured um signing to 1017 brick squad
and warner brothers records in 2009 he
became a mainstream artist with the
release of his singles oh let's do it
hardened paint hard independence hard
and pain oh like a basketball term i
would i would imagine that's what it's
about and no hands featuring rosco dash
and whale or is that a sexual with the
latter peaking at number 13 on the us
billboard hot 100. so he is a very we're
just out of touch we're out of touch
yeah yeah uh but aj's slightly out of
touch because he's mis slightly
misspelled it's waka so you pronounce it
waka flaka i don't know i think it's
whack a flock of fame black of like a
fight like a flack of flame um he says
he did it he's he's a vegetarian that's
cool and aj says he's a badass he sounds
like a badass he looks like a badass
hard independent um
hardened to paint
okay we should have him on the show
i bet he's huge if he'll have us yeah i
mean i know how arrogant to think that
wakka flakka would
that mr flame would just
do it
um but also back to aj but also jane
goodall told you too
he's very admonishing
you made your point aj i know you're
totally right please check in with us
about how it's going when you do i will
when you do yes he's not giving you the
option no no but i'm gonna i'm gonna
he's gonna try it definitely um thanks
for all you guys do bringing joy to
people etc
aj from indianapolis thank you aj um and
also thanks for the reminder because i
really do yeah you know veganism would
be very difficult because i mean think
about
losing eggs and
dairy and that would be i think that
would be impossible for me and but i do
think i could be a vegetarian
yeah
yeah
i do too i don't it's you know it's
really tough in the summer because we've
been
grilling barbecuing
and uh
well that's hard i don't know it's it's
tough i i love a burger but think about
how good you feel when you have i mean
that's the thing when you have
vegetables
now i'm thinking like
of would you rather is involving
meat versus
it's tough because like singularly i've
had more pleasurable experiences
with meat than like vegetables in
general you know they're yes i mean it's
it's tough but i i do love it but i
would say
i mean it's a different kind of pleasure
but i've had
maybe more pleasures from
a delicious dessert than i've had from
any single
like piece of meat i've had yeah it's so
it's so different but i know um but
again that's dairy i've had a lot of
pleasurable dairy experiences and that
would be very hard for me to give up
anyway i will keep you posted yes thanks
aj for the letter and if you guys would
like to write in our email address is
lifeisshortwondery.com
uh and thank you all for listening yeah
and thanks to our um guest today
the grammy award winning grand ole opry
member legendary musician
darius rucker could not be
more down to earth and cool i agree i
don't think it's possible i don't either
i think if you are more down to earth
you're putting it on
you know than that right that's like the
uh and i you know i'd love to see him
play i love country music and i would
love to see just to go to a concert now
his show in myrtle beach oh [ __ ] have
fun great with that but what a great
environment and um
how much he's doing too for
a good guy he does so much work for kids
saint jews but also you know i was
thinking like there probably are some uh
country music fans who
need to see that do you know what i mean
need to see somebody like darius um a
black person singing that music he's
whether he wants to be
or not he is
a trailblazer and he is
doing this amazing work for society i
think yeah being a african-american man
in his position
that's not his aim but it's still in
part the result and and like you said
doing so much for underprivileged kids i
mean like his presence in the world is
such a
it's so good and i'm so glad uh i got to
discover that because i would not have
known that had i not sat down and and
talked to him and uh it's hard to hear
that in like any sh that's what i love
about podcasts in a short form
interview it's more sound bitey you know
that's why it's we do have a good
podcast no i i meant in podcasts in
general all right but i think we do and
i hope you agree and i hope you uh stick
with us if you're listening for the
first time and go out and download
um his latest single my masterpiece and
his look for his album this fall thanks
to darius and yeah thanks to whichever
blowfish happened to listen to this
episode
and uh and to the original i wonder if
they're listening the ones who were
named after uh hoodie and the blowfish
and uh and check out our upcoming
feature about
uh the original hoodie the blowfish we
are currently in the works uh and check
out life is short um again next week and
lady of the matter september 17th it's
not gonna enjoy your week thanks oh
thank you
do i try it i don't wanna listen to life
short
that's pretty good life could be a dream
life could be a dream
follow life is short on apple podcasts
amazon music the wondery app or wherever
you're listening right now listen ad
free by joining wondery plus if you like
our show please give us a five star
rating and a review and be sure to tell
your friends another way you can support
the shows by filling out a small survey
at
wonderee.com survey
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan v monaco and senior producer on
this one and all of them is michelle
mish
there's also an audio engineer how could
i forget his name is sergio enriquez the
executive producer job his name is uh
marshall louis all of us do this under
the banner of
wandery
[Music]
tomorrow looks to be another day
relaxing by a lake
we haven't seen much actions
you should participate in the poetry jam
at the knox trail and this week
though the mosquitoes be aplenty
your fair hair keeps them
at bay
thoughts of your fair hair should study
for the low
you may be ever present in my mind
i know that your body your genitals
included
are many miles away
but the fact that they are warm and
moist and safe somewhere
in this beautiful country
that i hope to protect
you